scp-096 versus scp-1361  scp-096 may be an unstoppable force but  will  scp-1361 the all-devouring mass of  animal meat slurry be an immovable  object we all know scp-096 is tough it  shrugs off the biggest guns we have can  move at lightning speed and can track  down targets like a heat-seeking missile  scp-1361 is a giant roving blob of meat  that absorbs and digests its victims  adding to its ever-growing mass but we  personally think 096 would bring this  one home 1361 has the advantage of not  having eyes and thus could not activate  096's rage state but even if 1361 could  digest 096's flesh we'd bet money that  it couldn't put a scratch on the  monster's skeleton it would crawl out of  the blob and reform ready to maim and  maul another day